what is the studio session with dolph
and nipsey like are they giving each
other ideas who's like yo i got this is
who's doing the hook like like who like
like what is the creative vibe because
everyone who's a writer who's a rapper
some people don't write [ __ ] down some
people going to do punch in line by line
like what is that whole because that is
a moment in history that you were with
dolph and nip at the same time create
music like what is that like bro who
who's taking the lead in the session so
nick for sure he i didn't even know like
what was happening at first i just
pulled up we chopped it up for a second
he just went hopped in the booth you
feel me i hear him start laying his
vocals you know bar for bar so i'm like
okay like that's hard like i'm thinking
it's just i'm gonna watch bro do his
thing or something mm-hmm you come out
like you got something for this i'm like
hell yeah so i'll go in and i lay a hook
so they're like oh okay but the whole
time you know what i'm saying i was i'm
lying i was pulling up bro so you know
what i'm saying i'm getting faded
you know what i'm saying by that time uh
we like two records in we did two
records young dog pulled up later okay
okay so but like later that night so i
just remember waking up like so he was
like he was in a lean coma you woke up
and dolph was there
like
hey you know this dump right here and
i'm like oh it's still like you know
like okay this is crazy like you feel me
so the dog just vibing to the record
he'd go in
and start laying his focus bar for bar
and it was just you know what i'm saying
that was that it was it was it was crazy
because you know nip he got the studio
all blue his blue lights everywhere at
all times so you know what i'm saying it
was just like the vibe the energy was
crazy
is nip the kind of guy who would
lay his vocals down line by line or
would he like
without writing [ __ ] down i feel like it
depends how he felt
you know i'm saying some [ __ ]
he was you know
he was always intentional or some [ __ ] i
see him writing some [ __ ] down and you
know really kind of taking his time or a
different approach to it at least what
about you like obviously you have a lot
of melody so will you go in and like put
the melody down first feeling the lyrics
later like what's your process um
i kind of just jump in the booth uh
just play around with the melody a
little bit and uh just start filling in
the words honestly bro
a pattern i [ __ ] with
and then i just go with it just start
popping my [ __ ] fur